hey guys Pete here it's going to be a
short video today because when I came
home last night I saw a tweet that said
that IMDB had added Game of Thrones
season 7 episode 1 to the list and when
I went to the site sure enough there
were details about when season 7 was
going to premiere so there's no spoilers
here everyone can watch and the book
giveaway is still going on so make sure
you stick around to the end to learn how
you can enter so when I came home last
night my time which is I'm in the
opposite of the u.s. I saw a tweet from
geo T
Twitter that says that IMDB had added
the details for season 7 episode 1 sure
enough when you go to the IMDB site
episode 1 for season 7 is listed and the
release date is June 25th 2017 if we
look at a calendar we can see that
that's the last Sunday in June and then
there's five Sundays in July so we'll
get five episodes there and then the
last episode which will be episode seven
this season will be on the first Sunday
in August August 6 I have to admit it's
a little depressing to look at it that
way one week in June when we can August
and then July the shorter season looks a
lot shorter when you look at the
calendar beyond that there's not a whole
lot of information we didn't know
already my subscribers will know that
Jeremy Podesta is the director that's
listed there he's supposed to be doing
the season premiere and the season
finale in season 7 if you're wondering
who he is he did the first two episodes
of season 6 which were the red woman and
home and he also did episode 6 in season
5 which was the sand snakes episode
unbowed unbent unbroken the cast is
listed for episode 1 and it's pretty
comprehensive at first I thought maybe
it was the entire cast but there's two
notable people's names that are missing
after
their inspection and I don't want to
mention who they are since it is a one
of them is kind of a big spoiler if
you're avoiding spoilers so we can see
that pretty much all the major
characters will be in the first episode
basically we have Jon Snow
both Sansa and Arya all the people that
go along with them like three in Davos a
couple other northerners like Robert
Glover Lyanna Mormont and Megan
Parkinson which I believe is the
red-haired girl that we saw in the set
photos a while back her character
doesn't have her she's not listed as a
character but she's credited for being
in the episode we have Euron and his
niece and nephew seon and Yara
plus the sand snakes Olenna Tyrell Conor
McGregor's listed as we mentioned that
he will likely be playing a crew member
on your own boat the silence Jim
Broadbent listed without a character
name that is pretty much confirmed to be
he's going to be playing master a bro
sore archmaester a bros we have Daenerys
and all of her constituency grey worm
miss Andy Tyrion Queen Cersei and Jaime
are both listed the mountain his brother
the hound and probably what I would most
interested in personally is that we have
dollars Edie and bran listed here and
like I said I'm trying to stay away from
popping up spoilers so that's a part of
the story that I'm interested to see get
started right away
also Sam and Gilly Thoros Tom hopper is
listed as dick and Tarly and him and
randyll Tarly are both listed here Ellie
Kendrick who plays Mira and then we have
Qyburn and the one big shock that I
wasn't sure about at this point was that
Chris Van Houten is listed as playing
Melisandre in this episode there were
some earlier news where we thought we
might have seen her on set but that was
unsubstantiated and really there has
been no
Oh pictures or indications that she's
been anywhere except at home where you
know she has recently had a child so I
think it's safe to say that her hands
have been a bit full so that makes it
interesting that her name is listed here
and I think it's a safe bet that all
these people are actually going to be in
the episode because like I said there's
two major names missing and unless
they're just sort of trolling lined up
with everything we know from watching
the set and everything it would make
sense that neither one of these
characters are actually involved so is
this definitely don't mean that the
show's going to come out on that date
well not necessarily IMDB is not a
hundred percent accurate all the time
but I feel like this is a pretty good
indication because there was no
information there before and now it's
been added and it's not out of sync with
what we expected as far as the release
date in the first place so I'm thinking
it's just a confirmation and I think
this will be when we will see season
seven episode one that's about it since
I put out my weekly spoiler report
earlier so if you haven't watched that
please check that out there are some
interesting news about the actor who
plays Walder Frey some cool pictures
that showed up from the sets in Iceland
that have a little bit to speculate
about and if you're avoiding spoilers
check out my other video this week that
was about how many episodes actually are
left because there's been some
interesting reporting around that when
we thought that we know that season 7 is
going to be 7 but season 8 might be up
in the air so if you haven't watched
that one please check it out what do you
guys think I mean it does sound really
short now it's basically one week in
June all of July and one week in August
it'll be over August 6 as mentioned my
second book giveaway is under way and we
have only a few thousand more
subscribers to go until we hit the mark
the way it worked is all you have to do
is subscribe and leave a comment on this
video or any of the other videos where I
mention this giveaway and you're
eligible to win when I hit 28,000
subscribers I'll pick one of those
comments and I will send that commenter
a copy of the
illustrated edition 20th anniversary of
a game of Thrones by George R Martin
which is a beautiful book and a great
addition to any collection there'll be a
link in the description where you can
check it out if you haven't seen it yet
and if you're curious is how to how I
picked the winner you can just watch my
Dragonstone video from a couple months
back where I actually picked it and you
can see how I do it I use the random
picker and whatever so that's it for
today I got a lot of other stuff coming
out this week so please check back
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon